[Music]
hello everyone and welcome
to talk about it you the cloud I am from
alan gayle cloud engineer based at google
paris and in this episode we are going to
talk about governing tice and google coup
bernetti saint jean ou djiké see there
how these products work and
find out how they can be used
in the fantastic knitting architecture
once the lamp application migrated to
google cloud its mysql database
was first migrated to the
fully google cloud sql manager solution and
then s  'will make it ten apache has been
successful textures and in container docker
coup bernetti it is the open
source framework that will allow us to deploy and
manage several instances of these
containers in an architecture
distributed on several machines coup
bernetti jean scene called jica
and the product that will allow us to
deploy this type of architecture on
google cloud in a fully
managed way at the heart of bernetti costs
is the  e manifest
file a gamble configuration file that describes a
state in which we want to
deploy the containers of our
application
it is this file that we apply to
the underlying infrastructure
the application can accommodate
new modules therefore new
containers this  step so vary
over time to update it
just apply a modified version
of the yamal file that reflects this
change
let's take a closer look together at the
content of this file
first of all it defines an application
with a name with several  components a
persistent volume claim a
permanent disk a fuglseth stage so crest
is a service the secret' is a
secure way to store
sensitive information in coup bernetti this in
this case the username and password
allowing the front and web to
connect to the mysql database
the state fuglseth is a grouping of
several unique and persistent pods with
fixed names that  i are maintained
bernetti course this regardless of the
node on which they are run
a pod is the most basic object
deployable bernetti course and weave and
can run one or more containers
we notice in the definition of the temple
is of the pod the wordpress container of the
variables  environment indicating the
connection parameters to mysql loaded
from the cycle is as well as the
port number on which it is accessible 80
for http in our case the state pool
7 also indicates the number of
replicas of the pod wanted in this case
only one  to finish we
also find a service which is an
abstraction allowing customers
to access the pod in a homogeneous way
without worrying about their precise ip address
or the node on which it
runs
let's now move on to deployment on our
infrastructure of the state described  in this
yamal configuration file to
do this we must start by creating a
cluster coup bernetti sedan google
cloud suddenly bernetti scene jean this is
done using the command j cloud
containers kloster create
by default the cluster will be created with a
single batch of hens containing 3 nodes
so three virtual machines we
must specify the inability
alias parameter for  allowing one of the workbook
govern this to connect to
the ip address was depriving the sql cloud instance
a good security practice and lo and behold
our knitted container class tors
come to life the second step is to
recover security credits from
the newly created workbook  created
using the icloud containers command
kloster gate credentials as you
can notice the result of the
command is a cube config file which
contains secret dancers and which
will then allow us to use the
cube command that's her to  operate on the
knitting cluster in container this without
having to specify it explicitly each
time, moreover executing the command
cub is it for insp  ect the cluster
looking with the cub command is
it watching node the virtual machines
that have been created there are three of them
can find these same machines
in the google cloud console in the
menu computer jean vm instance the notes
are finally just virtual machines
the added value of bernetti costs
being the ease of interacting with
it it is not necessary to install
the application on each machine
individually governing this takes
care of it for us once our
application bild is in containers
everything  that we have to do and
describe what the echoes
bernetti manifest file will take care of launching them
somewhere on these nodes governing
tice is mainly an
orchestration tool that provides an
abstraction of the infrastructure
through a declarative api
the infrastructure  is therefore ready to cook
our application
we will first create an xp with the
cube command this is it create
namespace in  which we will
then deploy the application with the
cube command it is such a diploma that
takes part in putting the manifest file
we have deployed a single replica of the
pod verifying that this is indeed the case with
the cub command is it watching  pod
two interesting things are to note
first the node on which the friend is
running and then his ip address
if we execute the cube command
is it describe nodes we notice
each reserve a range of
ip addresses in which they allocate
addresses for each of these modes
individually
the service gives access to the pod in
which the wordpress containers are running
in another case the cub command
is watching for services allows us
to see that the service does not
yet have ip addresses  public so it
is not accessible on the internet we
assign a public ip address to the
service with the cube 7l patch
svc command after a certain time of waiting
this becomes visible in the  a
configuration of the service and
by accessing it in the browser
we can view the
configuration page of wordpress which
means that the application works
correctly
cost half mast and it also makes it possible to
easily modify the number of poor
in the event of a load increase with  the
command cube stealth key steve fostt
we will create three
additional replicas once the command has been
executed
we can follow the creation process
in the google cloud console and
view the details of the new pod
with the cub command.
the nodes on
which the new replicas were
created as bernie this
also provides the auto
skelling feature which allows to
automatically adapt to the load and we
invite you to discover it in more detail
by going through the description of the video
we are  arrived at the end of this
episode we saw together how to
use as bernetti etc or fooled
this saint jean to easily manage
a container architecture on
google cloud see
you in the next episodes
to discover together other
google cloud technologies
thank you for your attention and see you soon
[Music]